Land und Brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen Richard guten
Morgen Markus wo erreiche ich dich
gerade in einem etwas seelenlosen Raum
in der Leuphana Universität okay du bist
eingesperrt von wem wer war das ja
unheimlich liebevolle Menschen die mir
hier die bestmöglichen Voraussetzungen
für den Podcast zur Verfügung stellen
okay und was was machst du da gerade
Universität hat konferenzwoche und da
finden Diskussion statt vor den
Studenten aber auch vor Lüneburger und
sonstigen Publikum und da machen wir im
Augenblick Podiumsdiskussion zum Thema
alles mögliche wir haben über Ukraine
Krieg gesprochen wir haben äh ich habe
mit Karsten Brust da gesprochen dem
Kultur und Medien Senator von Hamburg
über die Zukunft der Demokratie okay ich
habe ihn am Anfang gefragt so zur Lage
des Landes
was für eine Note er dem Zustand der
Demokratie in Deutschland geben würde
jetzt bin ich gespannt hat zwei minus
gesagt und du würdest sagen das kann ich
zwei minus finde ich unterm Strich
richtig das gibt ein paar Sachen wo ich
eine vier oder eine 5 verteilen würde
aber es gibt auch andere Sachen wo ich
zwischen 1 und 2 bewerte und so als
Gesamtnote 2 - bin ich in Ordnung ja und
wo wo willst du 54 und wurde eins also
ich glaube nicht eins würde ich geben
funktionierende Institution ja das muss
man ja einfach mal im international
Vergleich sehen also insgesamt im
internationalen Vergleich geringe
Korruption und gut funktionierende
Institution also wir haben immer noch
viele Dinge Verfahren die gut
funktionieren
klar medial gucken wir immer auf das was
nicht funktioniert in diesem Land ne
aber oh du magst ne großer Philosoph hat
mal gesagt es ist auch in der Krise
immer mehr nicht Krise als Krise es gibt
in Deutschland sehr viele Dinge die
ziemlich reibungslos funktionieren im
Vergleich zu sehr vielen anderen Ländern
der Welt und da würde ich Deutschland
eine sehr gute gute gehen und wo sind
wir schlechter einer Meinung nach ja
also über Bildungssystem sind wir im
internationalen Vergleich mit Ländern
mit denen wir uns gerne vergleichen
nicht gut ich habe ja auch einige Kritik
an den Medien ein paar Mal in meinem
Leben geäußert da finde ich es auch noch
viel Luft nach oben also da gibt es
einige Dinge die man verbessern kann
Medienkritik ich erlebt das gerade so in
in der Sendung auch häufiger mal äh ich
und ich spreche es auch an wenn es
gerade passt aber ich merke immer da
haben alle so ein bisschen
Selbstkritik sind wir wirklich nicht gut
und und ich finde das dass das da müssen
wir alle gemeinsam wirklich dran
arbeiten das muss besser werden du hast
das richtige Stichwort gegeben die Luft
nach oben besteht darin in unsere Medien
selbstkritischer werden wenn sie schon
viel besser aber welches Beispiel über
Ukraine und so weiter haben wir schon
häufiger gesprochen ich denke so im
Nachhinein Aufarbeitung des Medien
Verhaltens in der corona-pandemie könnte
ausführlicher sein aber neulich gemacht
ne vor zwei Wochen ja ich habe gehört
nein ich habe es leider nicht gesehen
aber ich habe auch gehört dass
Lauterbach selbstkritische Dinge gesagt
und ja also waren waren vielerlei
Hinsicht eine denkwürdige Sendung und
ich ich hatte das Gefühl gerade wir
waren die dem Land auch schuldig und ich
werde das auch weiter betreiben weil ja
auch immer so dieses Gefühl entstand ist
Weise aus dem Running Gag ja also Karl
Lauterbach wohnt quasi bei uns und in
der Tat haben wir ja nun häufig uns mit
ihm ausgetauscht aber ich lege auch Wert
auf die Feststellung dass wir wirklich
also ich sag mal sehr kritische
Gespräche hat der Karl Lauterbach bei
uns zum Thema bist du eigentlich
Minister oder bist du
Influenza was ist dann Rollenverständnis
und so weiter auch die Frage nach den
Maßnahmen die Frage nach der
Kommunikation viele Dinge und in der
letzten Sendung haben wir eben
wenn wir noch mal wirklich in medias
Race gegangen um es mal sozusagen und da
war er selbstkritisch er war
selbstkritisch ich fand vor allem also
es war war nicht angenehm nicht einfach
für ihn weil es unter um einen Tweet
ging den er irgendwann mal nachts
abgesetzt hat bezog sich auf eine Studie
einer australischen epidemiologin und
das war eine wichtige Sache weil sie zum
Ergebnis gekommen war das Schulen Kinder
ja sehr wohltreiber der Pandemie seinen
Cluster und so weiter und und die
Schlussfolgerung war daraus dann im
Grunde wir müssen die Schulen wieder
dicht machen und er schrieb dazu ich
stimme zu und jetzt kann man natürlich
sagen da war noch nicht Minister und so
weiter aber war natürlich ein wichtiges
Gesicht ein wichtiger Spieler sozusagen
in dieser ganzen Pandemie und ich habe
dann gefragt ob er den wüsste wer diese
Frau eigentlich sei und das sagte ja das
ist eine sehr anerkannte australische
epidemiologin stellte sich raus sie ist
auch epidemiologin aber was sie vor
allen Dingen macht ist sie kümmert sich
bei älteren Aborigines um die Themen
Demenz und Inkontinenz
das heißt mit Epidemiologie hat die
schon auch zu tun aber eher am Rande und
es war dann sehr interessant weil er
sagte naja wir ich habe die zitiert die
die war da am Anfang die war sehr jös
und später war sie dann aber nicht mehr
so seriös und da habe ich sie weniger
zitiert das war kein guter Moment aber
was ich gut fand war dass er sich
gestellt hat und dass er sich immer
weiter auch der Diskussion stellt das
machen andere ja nicht und ducken sich
weg ja das finde ich gut dass er das mal
abgesehen davon ne dass ich ihn
persönlich überhaupt Schätze und das ist
nicht daher geredet also das ist ein ein
wahrscheinlich der gebildete und
Politiker den wir in Deutschland haben
also ich lass mich gern belehren dass
das noch jemand gibt der das toppt aber
mit dem kann ich mich also über
Philosophie auf höchstem Niveau
unterhalten und das ist dann
unglaubliche redlicher mensch das ist
das zweite was ich sehr ja er ist
integer und er ist redlich und er liegt
bestechlich enormes Wissen ja was aber
alles natürlich nicht geschützt dass man
mal die ein oder andere Entscheidung
trifft oder sich ein Festlegung macht wo
man im Nachhinein denkt könnte
vielleicht anders gewesen sein und was
ich wichtig finde ist dass wir darüber
reden weil wir müssen ja lernen aus
alledem ja die nächste Pandemie können
gerne kommen oder irgendeine andere Art
von Ausnahmezustand oder Situation und
deswegen ist es unglaublich wichtig dass
wir das Aufarbeiten und uns fragen was
wahr war und was wäre wahr
und da haben wir ja und das weißt du ja
selber in hochemotional aufgeladen ja
Freund feinschema hatte aufgebaut ja und
zwar viel zu steiler und viel zu hart ja
und daraus zu lernen dass ich das nicht
beim nächsten Mal wiederholt das wäre
glaube ich zu dem Thema Zukunft der
Demokratie sehr sehr wichtig und genau
und deswegen berichte ich auch davon
weil es gab noch einen zweiten sehr
interessanten Moment in dieser Sendung
kann man sich in der Mediathek auch noch
ansehen Heribert Prantl war da der
natürlich die Verfassung und die
Freiheit und die Grundrechte hoch hielt
ja sehr be wirkende Art und Weise und es
ging irgendwann um eine Situation
fünfter dezember 2020 ich habe zufällig
genau an diesem fünften dezember 2020
abends in Stockholm in klärender Kälte
vor dem Karolinska-Institut ein kurzes
Interview mit anders stegnell geführt
dem schwedischen staatsepidemiologen
weil wir diesen schwedischen Sonderweg
nachspüren wollten und verstehen wollten
was da passiert und ich stellt ihm
damals die Frage ob er den nicht Angst
hat irgendwann für die vielen Toten
schweden hatte er am Anfang sehr viele
Opfer zu beklagen gerade in den Pflege
und alles ganz genau ob er nicht Sorge
hat dass er irgendwann dafür zu
Verantwortung gezogen wird und der sagte
das kann sein aber wir müssen immer
alles im Blick haben wir müssen gucken
was macht das mit der Wirtschaft wenn
wir einfach lockdowns verhängen und vor
allen Dingen was macht das mit den
Kindern was macht das mit den Schulen
wer redet über diese ganzen Schäden die
da noch sind das war im Dezember 2020 er
hat das alles
glasklar gesehen und interessanterweise
und es war natürlich an irrsinniger
Zufall genau am selben Tag am 5 dezember
2020 setzt Karl Lauterbach einen Tweet
ab indem er anders sticknell genau
diesem Mann den Rücktritt empfiehlt aber
gut das war die das war die die muss
natürlich zurück überlegen ne das war
diese emotional enorm aufgeheizte
Situation genau die also auch einen
klugen intelligenten Kopf wie Karl
Lauterbach ja zu emotional
Reaktionen herausfordert weil wir haben
ja doch eigentlich uns immer gefragt und
immer offen gefragt machen die Schweden
das richtig oder machen die Schweden das
falsch genau und es war immer Mehrheit
bei uns zu sagen die Schweden machen das
falsch und ich weiß gar nicht wie ein
die Mehrheit war dafür zu sein die
Schweden machen das falsch weil wir uns
für einen anderen Weg entschieden haben
und es spannende ist eigentlich so wenn
man im Nachhinein ich würde das
bestreiten aber du meinst die Mehrheit
war für den schwedischen weg also ich
kann dir nur sagen aus Reaktion die wir
hatten aus Rückmeldungen dieser
schwedische Sonderweg ja so war das ja
bei uns gelabelt das hat die Leute total
fasziniert von Anfang an und das war
auch der Grund warum wir diese diese
Reportage gemacht haben bis heute
wirklich sehenswert finde ich damals mit
mit Silke Gondorf gemacht die die dann
ganz großartigen Job gemacht hat weil
man genau verstanden hat was da in
Schweden eigentlich passiert und es war
sehr interessant ich diese
Auseinandersetzung mit Karl Lauterbach
die Diskussion ich sagte zu ihm ist das
nicht wahnsinnig übergriffig ja also
einem Top Beamten eines anderen Landes
von Deutschland aus mal kurz den
Rücktritt zu empfehlen ja das würden wir
uns umgekehrt niemals bieten lassen das
war dann kann das war das eine nur
letzter Gedanke Richard doch diese diese
gewisse Überheblichkeit die da drin ist
und nach dem Motto wie wissen sie
ohnehin besser und das zweite ist
damals wusste man noch nicht genau was
der richtige Weg ist und ich habe
wirklich aus der Geschichte für mich
auch gelernt die Rechnung kannst du erst
ganz zum Schluss auch machen aufmachen
heute ist interessant wenn du dir
anschaust die Zahl der Toten in Schweden
auf eine Million Einwohner ungefähr
2250 und wir sind bei knapp 2000 das
heißt wir sind gar nicht furchtbar viel
besser als die Schweden aber wir haben
ein sehr sehr hohen Preis gezahlt die
Schweden haben nicht diese stark
polarisierte Gesellschaft und der der
härteste
anti-corona-protest weil sie noch das
waren den Stockholm waren glaube ich 15
Restaurantbesitzer die in der
Stockholmer Polarnacht ja protestiert
haben weil sie ihre Restaurants statt um
22 Uhr um 20 Uhr zu machen mussten das
war die härteste Anti Corona Demo die
ist jemals in Schweden gegeben hat und
unterm Strich muss man sagen aus
heutiger Sicht und das ist nicht besser
wissen sondern einfach einfach nur
lernen die die Schweden haben von Anfang
an das Ganze im Blick gehabt ich glaube
das haben wir viel zu verengt gesehen
meine Meinung und das zweite ist medial
medial hätten wir Stichwort Inkontinenz
bei älteren Aborigines auch als Medien
wir müssen noch viel kritischer
hinterfragen auf wen hören wir wer sind
diese Leute die das zitiert werden nicht
schützt uns davor genau zu recherchieren
ja das müssen wir viel gründlicher
machen dein Wort in Gottes Wort ja weil
also Kirche war berühmter Satz das Leben
kann nur vorwärts gelebt und nur
rückwärts verstanden werden geht ja für
alle großen Krisensituationen ganz ganz
besonderen was für ein schöner Satz oder
ja und das ist natürlich so dass in der
Situation wie damals als Politiker du
musst jetzt handeln du musst jetzt eine
Entscheidung fällen und du fällst die
Entscheidung dann im Zweifelsfall in
Deutschland im Punkto Sicherheit weil du
Angst hast die falsche Entscheidung zu
fällen und dann bist du im Zweifelsfall
auf der besseren Seite
das ist eine relativ gute Erklärung
dafür warum sich viel in Deutschland so
entwickelt hat wie sich das entwickelt
hat aber im Nachhinein betrachten wir
dann viele andere Dinge anders zum
Beispiel wissen wir dass jetzt der das
geimpfte trotzdem ansteckend waren am
Anfang hat man erzählt sind sie nicht
ich habe hier im Podcast zu dir gesagt
warum lasse ich mich impfen ich selber
habe keine Angst vor Corona aber ich
lasse mich impfen um andere nicht
anzustecken dann muss ich irgendwann
lernen ja das das Impfen überhaupt nicht
davor schützt andere anzustecken stellt
dann wieder in Frage warum ist denn das
in ganz großen Stil überall behauptet
worden also ist so das ist wichtig weil
er unredliche Motive am Werk sind
sondern weil man sagt man weiß Dinge
nicht man ist in Situationen die man
nicht genau durchschaut und was lernt
man daraus dass man nicht mit
holzhackerischer Sicherheit über solche
Dinge entscheidet und Leute die andere
Meinung haben diskreditiert und Einsatz
dazu wir haben wieder eine riesige Krise
wie bei der Ukraine und da empfehle ich
genau dasselbe ne die Entscheidung
können nur vorwärts gelebt werden ja
aber dieser dieser Krieg ja und diese
Verbrechen können rückwärts komplett
eingeordnet und verstanden werden und
hier geht wieder dasselbe ja nichts
gegen starke Meinungen aber andere
Meinungen grundsätzlich als unredlich
oder von üblen Motiven getrieben und so
weiter darzustellen das steht unserer
Demokratie nicht gut zu Gesicht denn
genau wie bei Corona müssen wir am Ende
zu geben dass wir dann immer weniger
gewusst haben als wir eigentlich hätten
wissen müssen um so rigorose
Entscheidungen zu treffen genau und das
das wiederum mochte ich so sehr schätze
ich so an jemandem wie Karl Lauterbach
da fällt dem kein Zacken aus der Krone
wenn er dann in der Sendung einfach sagt
da gab es Entscheidungen die waren
einfach totaler Schwachsinn so hat er
sich ausgedrückt zum Beispiel draußen
Maske tragen Joggen mit Maske nicht auf
Parkbänken sitzen und so weiter all
diese Dinge aber auch noch einige andere
Sachen mehr und sich dem zu stellen ist
natürlich wirklich ehrenwert weil die
einfache Nummer ist sich einfach
wegzudenken und du hast doch kein
Problem ich meine ist ja sehr
interessant zu sehen wie Angela Merkel
der der Debatte über die
russland-politik einfach aus dem Weg
geht du stellst dich einfach nicht und
dann hast du auch krank und dann kommst
du nicht in den medialen Fokus und dann
bist du einfach raus und das finde ich
aber nicht gut für eine Demokratie weil
ich das Gefühl habe dass man wenn man
anfängt Dinge ehrlich aufzuarbeiten und
zu betrachten dass das ist immer so ein
Moment der Erlösung den es dann gibt die
Leute sind schlicht und ergreifend dafür
dann auch schon dankbar weil sie sagen
okay sie haben es zumindest verstanden
was da möglicherweise nicht gut gelaufen
ist ich habe heute weil wir gerade so
eingestiegen sind und weil das wirklich
spannend ist mir fällt gerade ein
Interview ein dass ich dieser Tage
gelesen habe von Antonia Grunenberg
kennst du nie das ist eine kannte sie
auch nicht ist eine eine
Politikwissenschaftlerin die
über
Demokratie und die Frage Krise des
Liberalismus in welcher Situation sind
wir eigentlich
gesprochen hat und sie sagt etwas sehr
bemerkenswert ist da geht's um die
letzte Generation auch da wieder ne die
große Klimakrise Entscheidungen nach
vorne aber rückwärts verstehen und sie
wird gefragt ob sie diese
groteske-aktionismus den es da zum Teil
gibt diese Vorstellung von irgendwelchen
gesellschaftsräten ja also die dann
gegründet werden sollen und die dann
auch verbindlich sind für die Politik ja
also es wäre Deutschland quasi so eine
so eine Bananenrepublik ja die jetzt
noch mal Nachhilfe in demokratie braucht
und in Entscheidungsfindung ob wir das
Sorgen macht und sie sagt der ergeben
sich verblüffende Parallelen zu einer
totalitären Versuchung die wir schon mal
hatten und sie vergleicht das und sagt
da gibt es dieses selbstbewusste
Auftreten dieser junge Leute der Genuss
des öffentlichen Skandals also welcher
Triumph wenn man es schafft eine ganze
Autobahn oder ein Flughafen lahm zu
legen
und sie sagt unter kommt so ein
Kipppunkt rein weil man plötzlich das
Gefühl vermittelt Kompromisse auch in
der Klimafrage die sind schädlich das
darf nicht geben sondern es gibt nur die
eine reine wahre Lehre weil am Horizont
immer der Weltuntergang droht und sagt
diese Versuchung in diese totalitäre
Versuchung ja wir liegen richtig und die
anderen sind alle falsch die kam in
Europa schon ziemlich früh auf schon
Ende des 19 Jahrhunderts und hat dann
sagt sie in der Zeit zwischen den beiden
Weltkriegen
den Höhepunkt erreicht diese Lust an
totaler Zerstörung aus dem dann
Nationalsozialismus Faschismus
Stalinismus und so weiter erwachsen ist
natürlich bei mir ein Lieblingsthema an
weil ich vollende gerade in den vierten
Band meiner Philosophie Geschichte
und die Spiel zwischen 1900 und 1945 und
die produktivste Zeit der Philosophie in
Deutschland waren die 20er Jahre also
genau jene Zeit über die Frau
gruenbergner geschrieben hat und es ist
tatsächlich die Zeit der totalentwürfe
also der Bolschewismus
ne also alleinselig machende Politik
Ideologie die Anthroposophie ja die neue
Erfindung des Menschen durch Rudolf
Steiner ja es ist die Zeit der
Psychoanalyse freut oder also die die
die vor Gott ja das ist ja nicht dass
ich ja nicht nichts ne also das ist ja
ein Anschlag auf den Menschen
schlechthin zu sagen du wirst von deinen
unbewussten trieben bestimmt und der
Rest ist eigentlich nur Firlefanz und er
versucht irgendwie das Ganze zu
Beschichtung
völlig völlig neues Menschenbild ne zwei
große Triebe die dich hin und her reißen
heraus und tanatos ja zwischen zwischen
Geilheit und Todessehnsucht hin und
hergerissen ja bist du der Spielball
dann dunkler Mächte also das ist ja auch
eine total Erklärung des Menschen
zwischen Geilheit und Todes Sehnsucht
das gefällt mir es könnte der Titel über
deine Biografie werden Richard und jetzt
gibt ich könnte eine lange Liste machen
also von von von von von total
Erklärungen das ist ja denn der
Bestseller der damaligen Zeit ist Oswald
Spenglers der Untergang des Abendlandes
genau ja also alles geht ja von nun an
dem Bach runter ne auch auch was was
hier mit der heutigen Zeit zu tun hat
also die 20er Jahre von 100 Jahren haben
viele mit den heutigen 20er Jahren zu
tun es gibt einen interessanten
Unterschied diese ganzen
Entwürfe waren ganz häufig in den 20er
Jahren kollektive erlösungsfantasien
muss z.B oder mit der Anthroposophie
wird jetzt die ganze Welt besser ich
könnte wie gesagt Massen aufzählen an
Welt Erlösung Fantasien den er damaligen
Zeit entstanden sind
heute gibt es eigentlich keine
welterlösungsfantasien sondern es geht
eher um selbst erlösungsphantasien heißt
naja also die die Menschen die heute die
Welt besser machen wollen gehen dabei
auch immer mit sich selbst hart ins
Gericht ist das was ich jetzt sage nicht
irgendwie postkolonialistisch oder
rassistisch ja oder rassistisch und so
weiter also wir haben ganz viele Hürden
eingebaut der selbst Zensur beim denken
was dazu führt dass am Ende auch nicht
viel produktive Utopien dabei rauskommt
also wir sind vergrubelt man kann sagen
das hat das hat ja auch vielleicht ein
Vorteil ja also diese ganzen Welt
Erlösung Apostel der 1920er Jahre haben
sich um vieles nur überhaupt keinen Kopf
gemacht richtig und die heutigen machen
sich um alles einen Kopf und am Ende
kommt nicht mehr viel dabei raus
und das ist vielleicht irgendwie der
Unterschied aber dass man das Gefühl hat
die Weltgeschichte läuft schief alles
müsste anders so geht's nicht weiter das
große parallele weil so haben wir die
Welt in den 80er 90er Nullleiter nicht
gesehen sondern dies es geht nicht
weiter muss sagen in den 20er Jahren vor
100 Jahren ja Bank der Erste Weltkrieg
passiert die Uhr Katastrophe des
Jahrhunderts die absolute Urkatastrophe
aus Leichtsinn ja in ein irrsinnigen
Krieg reingeschlittert der der größte
Krieg war die Welt bis dahin gesehen hat
und ihn so keiner so genau so hatte
haben
nee sondern jeder der in diesen Krieg
gegangen ist hat gedacht das geht jetzt
relativ schnell zu Ende die guten Gewinn
und fertig und sich überhaupt nicht
vorstellen kann was für eine monströse
Katastrophe angerichtet wurde und auf
den Trümmern dieser alten Weltordnung
blühen jetzt die Lösung Fantasien das
ist der der Grund warum das die Zeit ist
und ich denke das vor grubenberg meinte
dass sozusagen das Ration Schule und das
liberale und so weiter in solchen Zeiten
immer einen schweren Stand hat ja sie
sagt also ist ganz interessant der der
Unterschied zu 69 ne also unter den
Talaren der muss von tausend Jahren und
so weiter ja die die die die die die die
68er und so weiter weg das da ging es ja
darum sozusagen diesen diesen ja Post
Nazi Nebel zu zerstäuben ja den einfach
aufzulösen aber heute sagt sie haben mir
das Gefühl jetzt wissen wir wie
Demokratie funktioniert
und sind dann ganz erstaunt wenn man
dann mitkriegen dass man das doch
irgendwie pflegen muss und dass es eben
kein Selbstläufer ist sondern dass man
sich darum kümmern muss und dass das
Vertrauen braucht und so weiter und das
Ergebnis ist dass mindestens ein Drittel
der Deutschen die repräsentative
Demokratie verachtet dass wir wissen
irgendwie gar nicht wirklich wie viel
ein Drittel ein Drittel der Deutschen
verachtet die repräsentative Demokratie
und hätte jetzt wissen wir spekulieren
lieber was ich habe das Gefühl die die
die haben das Gefühl wir brauchen mal
jemanden der jetzt mal das hör ich auch
häufig der jetzt mal durchgreift der mal
in Ordnung reinbringt der der mal sagt
was lang geht genau also ein eine Seite
die die die einen Führer wollen ja und
die andere Hälfte sind die Wahlen die
werden auch immer mehr Palio Liberalen
palion überall ja ich habe ich habe
meinen Aufsatz über parallel
überallismus gespielt
das ist dieser Song von Dean Martin in
Rio Bravo ja
liberal ist zu sagen ich brauche keinen
Staat das ist also quasi so ein
US-Import
parioliberalismus ist in den USA wo du
dich da überall rumgetrieben hast da im
Mittleren Westen und so weiter ja wo die
Busch wieder sage ich schon Trump wieder
zu Hause sind Busch wieder waren da auch
zu Hause ja genau und da ist es
sozusagen free spirit ja also so wenig
Staat wie aber irgendwie äh nötig ja
also man sieht das Militär ein und die
Polizei und der Rest der kann eigentlich
verschwinden das ist der Paleo
Liberalismus und der hat in Deutschland
relativ viele Anhänger gewonnen also
diese allgemeine Ablehnung des Staates
was ist der das Gegenteil ne der starke
Führer soll ja sozusagen der
personalisierte machtstaat sein und dann
gibt's die Leute die sagen also komm
bleibt mir mit dem ganzen Staat wäre
dieses dieses Gefühl das sozusagen diese
dass wir diese Demokratie nicht mehr so
richtig wertschätzen dass das auch
dieser der Liberalismus in gewisser
Weise gefallen siehst du das auch so ich
guck dir mal letzten Wahlergebnisse zum
Beispiel der FDP an ich meine fünf Mal
bei Landtagswahlen richtig auf die Mütze
gekriegt und und ich frage mich immer
was was läuft da gerade eigentlich so
verkehrt warum warum können wir uns mit
dieser Idee nicht mehr so richtig
anfreunden was ist eigentlich
Liberalismus ich genau ich würde geben
widersprechen weil ich sagen würde die
FDP ist nicht die Verkörperung der Idee
des Liberalismus ich würde das nicht
gleichsetzen weil ich würde sagen dass
alle Parteien der Mitte in Deutschland
das sind inzwischen ziemlich viele ja
sich zu den Grundwerten des Liberalismus
bekennen ist also nicht so dass der
Liberalismus in Deutschland eine Partei
braucht weil er nur in ihr vorkommt
deswegen würde ich diese Gleichsetzung
nicht machen und ich glaube die FDP
leidet im Augenblick darunter dass wenn
man sich die Frage stellt was war
eigentlich die Idee der FDP für die
nächsten vier Jahre also mit welcher
Agenda ist sie in die Koalition
eingetreten
und das würdest du jetzt in der
Fußgängerzone Fragen dann kippen
verneinungsformeln dann käme kein
Tempolimit ja sowas zum Beispiel also es
ist klar was die FDP nicht will aber ich
glaube in der Öffentlichkeit ist so eine
Agenda die wollen jetzt unbedingt noch
das erreichen und das erreichen und das
Erreichen in der Regierung da das ist
nicht sichtbar ich will nicht sagen das
nicht vorhanden aber es ist nicht
sichtbar und dann denkt man sich die FDP
ist eigentlich nur damit beschäftigt
dass zu verhindern was die Grünen wollen
das ist im Augenblick so den Eindruck
den man bekommt und darunter leidet die
Parteien und hat das auch damit zu tun
dass wir uns selber sozusagen keine also
die Vorstellung was ist eigentlich
Liberalismus und was bedeutet eigentlich
wirklich Freiheit wann ist dieser
Gedanke du hast dich ja viel damit
beschäftigt wann ist dieser Gedanke
eigentlich das erste Mal sozusagen in
diese Gesellschaft wer hat das
entwickelt weil wir waren ja lange Zeit
keine freien Gesellschaft ne genau also
sehr überlegen ne 17 Jahrhundert alles
aristokratische gesellschaftschaften
also es gibt mehr oder weniger über
einen König und da drunter gibt es eine
Adelsgeschichte das Land und dann
entwickelt sich ganz langsam dass
Manufaktur Wesen und der Adele war ja
dadurch geadelt dass er nicht arbeitete
aber innerhalb der arbeitenden Schicht
entstand eine neue Schicht das später
dann sogenannte Bürgertum
und das Bürgertum hatte das Interesse
selber über seine Geschicke verfügen zu
können und brauchte jetzt eine
Weltanschauung Ideologie Philosophie
egal wie man das nennen muss das auf
anderen Grundsätzen basierte als der
Adele der adelbasierte darauf die Welt
ist von Gott so eingerichtet dass der
Adel die anderen regiert und beherrscht
und weil ohne Herrscher geht's nicht und
das Bürgertum setzt dagegen also von
dieser von dieser top down Vorstellung
ne gott hat das so eingerichtet von
unten auf und entwirft so Szenarien
stellen wir mal vor es gäbe keinen Staat
und es gebe nichts und es gebe so ein
Uhr Zustand auf was man sich dann so
einigen würde und da entstehen Theorien
von Gesellschaftsverträgen also was wäre
es kommt Neues Begriff auf Fairness
spielte überhaupt keine Rolle in
adelsgesellschaften existierte gar nicht
und jetzt kommt dieser Gedanke wie sehr
denn eine faire Gesellschaft aus da
müsste doch eigentlich jeder das gleiche
Recht haben und was für Rechte wären das
denn ja zu müssen bis ein Recht haben
also auf Leib und Leben und dann muss er
ein Recht darauf haben sein Besitz
behalten zu dürfen ganz wichtiges Thema
immer im Liberalismus weil der dir eben
gefährdet war ne in den
adelsgesellschaften was was wird wenn
ich jetzt in erfolgreicher Kaufmann oder
Händler bin ich fahre zu den Messen
nicht verkaufe meine Tücher mit
erfolgreichem Manufaktur ich habe aber
keine Rechte da habe ich ja ständig die
Angst dass ein autokratischer Staat ja
mich nicht hochkommen lässt oder in
machtet und jetzt entsteht für die
politische Repräsentation des Bürgertums
der Liberalismus natürlich ist das
entwickelt worden von Philosophen aber
nicht einfach nur weil die so in ihrer
Stube saßen und darüber nachdachten
sondern weil die ganz eng gefangen waren
und im Austausch mit diesen Problemen
die haben zum Teil waren die Angestellte
oder haben gearbeitet
für Emporkömmlinge des Bürgertums und
der bedeutendste von denen war John
Locke der ist in einem Verhältnissen
geboren Engländer ja bei Arzt und soll
dem englischen König das Leben gerettet
haben ob das so stimmt oder nicht weiß
ich nicht hat auf jeden Fall da nicht
als Arzt praktiziert sondern er hatte
eine Stelle im Kolonialministerium das
war Ende des 17 jahrhunderts sind
interessanter Posten ja weil man nämlich
gerade dabei war die USA zu
kolonialisieren und weil man im
Sklavenhandel ganz groß aktiv war das
waren zwei sehr lukrative
Einkommensquellen allerdings und
dergleichen John Lock der also sagt
gleiche Rechte für alle Freiheitsrechte
der Sohn ihn Idealbedingungen entwirft
unter denen man sagen kann das ist ein
guter Gesellschaftsvertrag
der rechtfertigt allerdings die Kolonien
in den USA der selber hat als Lohn für
seine Arbeit Kolonialbesitz in Carolina
bekommen und das Interessante ist am
Anfang hatte noch die Möglichkeit dass
theologisch zu erklären also die guten
Liberalen waren damals noch keine
Atheisten man brauchten den lieben Gott
noch ja und zwar mit der Erklärung dass
das die Indianer das von Gott geschenkte
Land brach liegen lassen ja also gott
hat den Engländern England gegeben und
was haben die Engländer daraus gemacht
ja die haben die Bäume alle gerodet
überall Felder angelegt und so weiter
Baumwolle angebaut Schafe drauf halten
lassen die haben also Gott gefällig den
Acker Backert nur die gute Küche haben
sie irgendwie vernachlässigt aber das
nur am Rande das ist auch eigentlich
eine Art von Gotteslästerung und was
machen die blöden Indianer mit ihren
Zelten ja die kommen da hin als Nomaden
ja und dann die bearbeiten das Land
nicht ne also locker schreibt wirklich
ne was ein Bauer in der Wünsche aus dem
Acker rausholt ja da hat er Indianer
überhaupt keine Ahnung von er wollte den
20-fachen Ertrag aus dem
ja jetzt müssen natürlich die Leute aus
England kommen und den Indianer mal
zeigen wie das geht ja dass man da so
kann man mit Land nicht umgehen
Völkerrecht gab es zwar schon ne grzius
Völkerrecht ist älter als das wurde aber
damals nicht ernst genommen ne also muss
man den Leuten die ihren Grund und Boden
nicht richtig machen muss man den Weg
nehmen und deswegen ist das völlig
legitim den faulen Indianern die Erde
wegzunehmen und die gute englische Art
und Weise zu machen das sind ja und auch
den Sklaven haben wir heute
gerechtfertigt weil er sagt ja man sieht
ja daran die werden sich nicht ne und
ein Mensch der sich nicht wehrt wenn er
gefangen genommen wird ja der hat auch
keine Freiheitsrechte der ist sozusagen
ein Gemüse Sklave my reifel and me die
Macht desjenigen der die Waffe in der
Hand hat ne ja und der der der
überlassen
das heißt also der wichtigste Gedanke
ist starthhaltig raus das ist der
absolute zentrale Gedanke dahinter
übrigens auch interessant der Staat darf
auch was man Privatleben anbelangt also
Gedanke überhaupt nicht rein reden also
was ich in meiner Ehefrau anstelle geht
den Staat nichts an ob ich meine Kinder
schlage oder verkaufe oder was weiß ich
was geht den Staat nichts an das ist die
ursprüngliche Grundlage des Liberalismus
und ich wenn ich jetzt über John Lock
Rede es ist ja nicht so als ob das nicht
faszinierend wäre also nicht die
Gedanken die ich gerade ausgepackt habe
ne das ist die Nachtseite des
Liberalismus dass dieser Liberalismus
erfunden wurde für alle wohlhabenden
weißen Männer und die der Liberalismus
wäre nicht so ein Erfolg gewesen wenn er
seine Klientel nicht Stück für Stück
vergrößert hätte klar also wenn er nicht
irgendwann die Frauen mit einbezogen
hätte die Zielgruppe erweitert ja und
wenn er nicht irgendwann auch mal die
Sklaverei abgelehnt hätte und wenn man
so ein Stück für Stück irgendwo einsieht
dass das was wir wohl haben eine weiße
Männer gibt für alle weißen Männer gilt
und dass sie nicht nur für Männer gilt
und dass er auch für alle Menschen auf
diesem Planeten geht und das ist
sozusagen der ex-panding Circle ja also
der lieberalismus wird immer lieber
aller je mehr Interessen er in sich
aufnimmt und nur deswegen konnte er
natürlich zu einer solchen
Erfolgsgeschichte werden dass man sagt
das ist die Grundierung unserer
freiheitlichen Gesellschaften geworden
und ist für dich sozusagen dieser
Liberalismus der musste gerade als du
das gesagt hast mit dem Start halte ich
raus an Ronald Reagan denken die haben
neulich ein altes Interview mit Donald
Dragon angeguckt der auch so ein
Inbegriff ja alles alles liberal ist und
der der sagte wissen Sie wenn Sie zu
Hause sitzen und es klopfte an der Tür
und vor der Tür steht einer und sagt
guten Tag ich bin vom Staat dann machen
sie die Tür ganz schnell wieder zu und
laufen sie so schnell sie können das war
die Haltung des amerikanischen
Präsidenten zu seinem eigenen Staat
verrückt aber könnte auch wenn Donald
Trump sein könnte
Liberalismus blüht in den USA
bekanntermaßen
und die Staatsverdrossenheit ist daher
wenn es also bei uns ein Drittel sein
sollen was ein wahnsinnig hoher Wert ist
ist natürlich in USA noch sehr sehr viel
höher da will ich gar nicht wissen wie
hoch die ist ja also in den USA ich
meine du weißt ja da gibt es ja auch
Leute das Silicon Valley zum Beispiel
man die fragt mich ja auch jemand wie es
Steve Jobs z.B von Apple ne der hat das
ja mal sehr gut auf den Punkt gebracht
und sagte unser Auftrag ist es die Welt
als einen besseren Ort zu verlassen als
wir ihn vorgefunden haben das klingt
erstmal so selbstlos und altruistische
Filme aber nicht so sicher ob es in der
Auswirkung in der Konsequenzen nur so
sein wird also wie ich Firmen im Silicon
Valley sich wohlklingende Mutti
ausgegangen haben ja die don't Bee will
nicht böse sei nicht böse Weg das
natürlich den Sinn für das Nachdenken ja
da fragt man sich natürlich wenn sich
jemand schon so ein Spruch ausdenken
muss dann hat er schon schlechtes
Gewissen sonst kommt er gar nicht auf
die Idee dass damit zu machen aber du
hast natürlich recht eben silic in der
Nähe blüht der paleoliberalismus auch
und man darf nicht vergessen dass
Silicon Valley würde es gar nicht geben
wenn nicht ein starker Staat ja es
gegründet hätte das war ja bewusstes
Programm also die Amerikaner dass das
Land des palio-liberalismus ist auch das
Land der großen staatlichen
Förderungsprogramme das geht für die
Raumfahrt und mit dem was das alles
technisch möglich gemacht hat und das
geht auch für das Silicon Valley also
eigentlich ist der Grund und Boden auf
dem sie sind und die ganzen
Vergünstigungen die man dort hat und so
weiter eigentlich alles entstanden weil
der Staat das wollte und irgendwann
glaubt man dass man den Staat eben nicht
mehr braucht ne also absolute Inbegriff
eines Paleo lieber ich weiß Peter Thiel
ja also rechts von Peter Thiel ist nur
noch die was
sagen
und der träumt ja von einer Insel ja
jenseits der USA wo er keinerle
Rechtsprechung mehr unterliegt also das
hat sowas James Bond
aber das ist ein hoch angesehener Mann
im Silicon der der ganze Mann hat was
James bondartiges ja stimmt das ist ja
das ist ja der deutsche Abstammung wir
haben schon mal über ihn gesprochen
glaube ich Frankfurter Wurzeln und ist
man weiß nicht genau wie reicht der ist
irgendwo zwischen zwei und vielleicht 8
Milliarden Dollar spannend sind die
Leute die deswegen nicht in der Forbes
Liste schließen weil man nicht weiß wie
viel Jahre ja das geht für Peter Thiel
und das gilt auch für den Sultan von
Brune ja das stimmt und ich glaube auch
die die meisten arabischen Prinzen sind
da nicht drin ja das wobei ich Peter
Team nämlich eines ab das ist ihm nicht
ums Geld geht für den ist Geldmittel zum
Zweck der Paypal mit gegründet dann aus
bei Facebook ganz früher eingestiegen
genau und Mark Zuckerberg der der Chef
von Facebook wenn der sagt wer die
Menschen sind die ihn geprägt haben dann
fällt als erstes der Name Peter Thiel
und was interessant ist ist ja also was
sozusagen aus dieser großen Freiheit die
man erstmal hat und wo man sagt das
erwarten wir staathaltig raus wir machen
das schon und don't be evil wir machen
das auch gut wie das dann plötzlich so
ein Eigenleben entwickelt das finde ich
ja schon interessant am Beispiel von
Peter Thiel finde ich kann man das auch
aufhängen ne Thiel hat Paypal mit
gegründet und dann war ja irgendwann
klar okay da finden auch illegale
Geldtransfers statt das war 98 und als
das Unternehmen dann also payPal hat
dann eine Software entwickelt um diese
Kriminellen Kunden zu identifizieren und
du ich weiß nicht ob du das kennst wenn
du wenn du PayPal regelmäßig nutzt dann
dann kannst dir passieren wenn du
manchmal irgendwie Leuten Geld schickst
regelmäßig kommt irgendwann mal die
Frage ist das jetzt hier ein Geschäft
oder ist das wirklich privat und so
weiter also da stehst du sehr schnell
und der Verdacht komische Geldtransfers
zu machen
eigentlich ursprünglich eine gute Sache
don't be evil
genau ich weiß Elon Muskat mal erzählt
was der Grund ist oder der Grund dafür
war der hing ja da auch mit drin PayPal
zu gründen der Grund war er wollte sich
mit seiner Mutter regelmäßig so kleine
Geldbeträge hin und her schicken und es
ging ihm wahnsinnig auf die Nerven wie
kompliziert das bei großen Banken war
und das war sozusagen die Geburtsstunde
von Paypal was interessantes ist die
Algorithmen ne die diese PayPal konnten
sozusagen nach schmutzigem Geld
durchsuchen und durchkämmen die bildeten
dann später die Grundlage für eine ganz
andere Technologie und jetzt don't be
evil Vorsicht an der Bahnsteig kannte
Peter Thiel hat dann 2004 palat hier
gegründet ne so das ist eine Firma die
dann sozusagen für Verteidigung für die
Frage wie finden wir Terroristen in
diesen ganzen Daten Bergen und so weiter
und so fort
das ist eine sehr dubiose Firma und das
ist die Firma von der ich sagen würde da
gibt es dann so ein Bruch und da kommt
dann auch konsequenter Weise die Idee
heraus lass uns auf irgendeiner Insel
also
Hoheitsgewässer irgendwo weit draußen wo
kein Staat was zu tun hat da machen wir
unsere ganz eigenen Regeln und plötzlich
träumst du von etwas das hat eigentlich
mit dem Staat der dir auch deinen
Reichtum ermöglicht hat gar nichts mehr
zu tun und plötzlich bist du nicht mehr
ganz klar auf der Seite dieses Staates
und plötzlich triffst du Donald Trump
und plötzlich bist du jemand der in ganz
seltsamen Gewässern unterwegs ist und
das passiert dann irgendwann ne also
wenn man jemanden alle erdenklichen
Möglichkeiten gibt dann wird er auch
weil er eigentlich ein Schnapsideen
kommen
und ja und deswegen sieht man es gibt
grenzendes Liberalismus ja und das hat
ja Liberalismus in seiner Geschichte
auch gelernt also eigentlich hat er
palio-liberalismus sich stark verändert
und Lok hat tut tree tises about
government geschrieben also Vorstellung
wie müsste eigentlich eine gute
Regierung aussehen die Liberalen
Grundsätzen genügt und das ist
eigentlich immer weiter ausgearbeitet
worden und ausgearbeitet und verfeinert
und irgendwann wurde der Liberalismus
eben Stück für Stück auch sozialer bis
hin zu den großen Synthesen die mANEO
Liberalismus nennt und jetzt weil viele
die uns zuhören den Begriff anders
verwenden der Neo Liberalismus auf dem
die soziale Marktwirtschaft basiert
hatte das Prädikaten nio nicht weil er
radikaler Liberalismus ist sondern weil
er versucht hat die Errungenschaften des
Sozialismus mit den Errungenschaften des
Kapitalismus zu einem liberalen Ganzen
zusammen ne und das war in den 30er
Jahren
20er Jahren angefangen ja sondern haben
wie weiter Rücken Müller armak Wilhelm
Röpke das sind die eigentlichen Väter
der sozialen Marktwirtschaft gewesen und
zwar in harten Zeiten die soziale
Marktwirtschaft entsteht als
Konkurrenzmodell gegen den Faschismus
und gegen den rollstuismus
weil zum damaligen Zeitpunkt auch noch
nicht abzusehen war dass das mal enden
würde Faschismus relativ schnell wollte
wissen muss deutlich später und auch
nicht klar war wie wirtschaftlich
erfolgreich das ist also musste sich die
bürgerliche Gesellschaft etwas ausdenken
was alles das was diese Ideologien an
ihr kritisiert hatten ja dass die Arbeit
ja schlecht bezahlt waren und
ausgebeutet worden und so weiter das
auch die bürgerliche Gesellschaft eine
Klassengesellschaft war die man da
möglichst gegensteuert und das ist dann
die Grundlage gewesen der sozialen
Marktwirtschaft Ludwig er hat das
interessante was zeigt ja im Grunde dass
sozusagen nichts einfach gegeben ist
dass er häufig das Gefühl dass wir haben
wie wir also ich bin in dem Bewusstsein
aufgewachsen ja klar alle paar Jahre
geht man mal zum wählen und dann gibt es
dieser Parteien und die machen das mal
schlechter und mal besser aber das ist
sozusagen unser unsere Welt und als als
junger Mensch der das einfach so
inhaliert
stellt man dieses System natürlich nie
in Frage aber man sieht nie was alles
funktioniert auch erstmal muss man ja
auch sagen man sieht nicht was
funktioniert und man sieht auch
sozusagen nicht was die Alternativen
sind also welche schlimmen Optionen ist
eigentlich noch gibt ne mit anderen
Worten man weiß nicht zu schätzen was
man hat das ist so aber das kennt ja
jeder aus der Erziehung seiner Kinder
ja also man weiß nur zu schätzen was man
hat wenn man das mal nicht gehabt hat ne
aber wenn etwas Selbstverständliches
dann wachsen immer neue Ansprüche nach
und dann ist es auch ganz normal dass es
passiert dass man in diesen Ansprüchen
sich auf Holzwege versteigt ich meine es
ist ja auch das Ziel der Jugend nicht
die Eltern dazu haben es ist das Ziel
junger Menschen gegebenes in Frage zu
stellen ja und nicht anzuerkennen was
alles an Gutem da ist und ich finde das
gehört einfach zu zu jungen Menschen
dazu weil wenn das nie so ist dann gibt
es auch keine Kreativität zur positiven
Weiterentwicklung das heißt also immer
muss das bestehende von jeder Generation
neu auf dem Prüfstand gestellt werden
das ist wichtig und das gehört dazu aber
du hast trotzdem recht dass das was gut
ist und das was funktioniert ja und die
nichtkrise in der Krise die Dinge sind
die wir im Regelfall zu wenig zu
schätzen müssen ja es gibt ja also wenn
du wenn du überlegt es gibt da sozusagen
die diese Sehnsucht und daraus glaube
ich resultiert ja auch so ein großer
Teil dieser Demokratie Verdrossenheit
würde ich mal sagen diese Sehnsucht
sozusagen nach dem starken Anführer und
jetzt könnte man sagen gut dann guck dir
mal die schlimmen Beispiele an guck dir
jemanden wie Putin an das will keiner
aber wenn du z.B mit Leuten anfängst zu
diskutieren über die frage ich ihn Ping
ja das chinesische System
da fällt die Antwort nicht mal so
eindeutig aus dann kommt jemand haben ja
neulich darüber gesprochen wie Paul
kalkarame ja der Präsident das Ruanda
und sagt na ja also während ihr uns ein
Fahrradweg baut mit euren komischen
Demokratien haben uns die Chinesen schon
zwei Flughäfen hingestellt und so weiter
und dann könnte man denken dass doch
eigentlich ein gutes System naja ich
kenne die persönlich ehrlich gesagt
niemand also wirklich niemanden mit dem
ich hier geredet habe der der sagt ich
finde China toll nein aber ich kenne
ganz viele die sagen die können Dinge
wahnsinnig schnell machen so wie wir das
früher ja auch mal konnten ne also es
gibt viele Dinge die früher mal in
Deutschland möglich waren die heute
nicht mehr gehen also in Kölner Dom
könnte man heute nicht mehr bauen er
wird keine Baugenehmigung für die du
hättest nicht die Handwerker die du alle
brauchst die machen ja und dann würde
man kalkulieren das zu bauen und würde
sagen das kostet 800 Millionen und am
Ende kostet es 4 Milliarden und dann ist
das Geld nicht dafür da und soweit ich
könnte das jetzt breit ausmalen ja
Neuschwanstein z.B wird auch keiner mehr
bauen der neuschwanstein ist aus Pappe
das aus Pappe das könnte jeder Freund
also das ist ein Filmkulisse im Grunde
das ist unglaublich billig und schwer
auf bitte nein wirklich also das ist neu
Schwanstein ist schon als Fake
geschlossen
ja das ist überhaupt nicht hochwertig
das ist überhaupt nicht komm bitte auch
die Fraueninsel zum Beispiel in Berlin
ne da stehen ja auch so Lustschlösser
drauf das ist alles so billig
zusammengeschustert bist sorry aber es
war ja auch nur als Spielplatz gedacht
ja und Neuschwanstein war ja auch nur
als Spielplatz gedacht nee aber aber man
könnte ganz ganz viele Dinge machen also
vieles von dem was was Deutschland heute
ausmacht an Ingenieursleistungen und
sowas alles würde heute alles nicht mehr
gehen sondern gibt es eine Menge von
Gründen warum das nicht mehr geht und
das ist natürlich so ich habe das auch
häufig als Stimmen aus der Wirtschaft
gehört die immer gesagt haben die sollen
wir denn und Konkurrenzkampf mit China
bestehen wenn das bei uns alles ein
juristischer Schritt nach dem anderen
und dann wird im Namen der Hamster
geklagt oder der rohrdommelwirbel nicht
zu vergessen während und so weiter ja so
ich würde das ja nicht ins lächerliche
ziehen weil ich ja diesen Gedanken an
sich nicht uninteressant finde ja dass
die Natur irgendwo auch ins Recht
gesetzt werden muss weil du sonst immer
verliert und nicht mehr so viel übrig
ist aber auf der anderen Seite
wäre der Kompromiss zu sagen ja wir
müssen die Natur ins rechts setzen
vielleicht sogar stärker als bisher aber
wir müssen die juristischen
Verfahrenswege verkürzt dass der Punkt
das heißt also das Klagen über so viele
Instanzen über so viele Jahre sondern es
ist einfach so man muss am Anfang quasi
eine Art politische Entscheidung treffen
ja und nicht versuchen über juristische
Wege das ganze in die unendliche Länge
zu ziehen und da sind wir ja Weltmeister
drin und das war mal gut dass wir das
machen ich betone ja oft Demokratien
sind mit Absicht langsam richtig mit
Absicht genau das ist gut dass sie
langsam sind das darf kann man nicht
genug betonen bei den alten Griechen als
die Demokratie erfunden wurde da wurdest
du an einem Tag angeklagt an einem Tag
verurteilt und am selben Abend
hingerichtet ja es ist effizient aber
bei uns hat man hat man versucht das
System langsamer zu machen um es weniger
störanfällig zu machen Checks und
Balance ist gegen Missbrauch
komplizierte juristische Verfahrenswege
um eben keine schnellen
Fehlentscheidungen zu treffen und so
weiter und so weiter das ist alles
wertvoll
führt aber dazu dass in Dingen wo also
jetzt das Tempo so hoch ist wie bei der
nachhaltigkeitsrevolution und so weiter
dass wir tatsächlich zu langsam sind
oder dass wir eben eine Bauprojekte oder
sowas machen uns dafür entschieden haben
dass eben dann 10 oder 15 Jahre dauert
bis man sowas machen kann und so und das
ist natürlich nicht gut und da gibt es
dieses schielen nach China und ich denke
mir immer es muss verdammt viel bessere
Ideen geben als irgendein Mist von den
Chinesen zu übernehmen um das
interessanter zu machen und da hat mir
da hat mir jetzt vor ein paar Tagen ja
als ich jetzt hier eine Leuphana
Universität mit Carsten prostag
diskutiert habe gesagt es gibt so eine
Stanford Kommission und die hat sich
darauf spezialisiert so Verfahrenswege
zu finden wie bringen wir alle an einem
Tisch ja um innerhalb von kürzester Zeit
zu guten gemeinsamen Entscheidung zu
kommen das ist hoch interessant da will
ich nicht mal ein bisschen rein
vertiefen ob das funktioniert zum
Schluss noch mal richard hat ein letzter
Gedanke ich habe dieser Tage gelesen
dass wir
unfassbar Zäune bauen
also irgendwie trauen wir uns auch
selber nicht mehr so richtig über den
Weg wusstest du dass die EU mittlerweile
an den Außengrenzen tausende Kilometer
Zaun und Mauern hat
2015 hatten wir 315 Kilometer Zaun rund
um die oder irgendwo an EU-Außengrenzen
irgendwo hört der Liberalismus auf ja
innerhalb von sieben Jahren ist das auf
das Siebenfache angewachsen
2048 km und es kommen mittlerweile
hunderte Kilometer dazu das heißt
irgendwie haben wir auch nicht so
richtig Vertrauen in unser eigenes
System und in die Stärke dieser
Demokratie ja ja zumindestens haben wir
kein Vertrauen darin wenn zu viele
Menschen von außen dazu kommt dass die
Stabilität erhalten bleibt also ich
glaube was wir ja nicht betrachtet haben
ist ja jetzt sagen wir mal der der
liberale Westen ein Relation zum Rest
der Welt
in das Problem ist natürlich dass dieser
anspruchsvolle Liberalismus den wir
haben also dieser soziale Liberalismus
die soziale Marktwirtschaft nur unter
günstigen Bedingungen gedeihen kann das
ist der Grund warum man auch nicht
hingehen kann und die einfach in
irgendwelche anderen Länder bringen ein
guter Punkt sondern das sind sehr guten
Nährboden braucht also man braucht man
braucht über lange Zeit funktionierende
Institutionen man braucht eine
überdurchschnittlich gebildete
Bevölkerung man braucht Wohlstand man
braucht Wohlstand man braucht gut
funktionierende Medien und so weiter es
gibt ganz ganz viele Dinge die Stimmen
müssen damit es wirklich funktionieren
kann und im Regelfall ist das ein ein
kultureller Prozess der man gut und
gerne ein Jahrhundert dauern kann gerade
wir Deutschen waren unglaublich
schlechtere mir waren die letzten ne wir
mussten also erst das faschistische
gruselige Experiment machen bisher dann
irgendwann dadurch das auch verloren
haben zwangsbekehrt wurden und dann
gesehen haben oh es bringt ja noch mehr
Wohlstand als andere scheiße das ist ja
nicht so als ob wir da großer Vorreiter
werden aber zum Thema was ist gut an
Deutschland
wir machen das seit Gründung der
Bundesrepublik ziemlich gut wir machen
das auch ziemlich viel besser als die
Amerikaner das machen oder als sie
Engländer das machen und so siehst du
soziale Marktwirtschaft ist wäre
eigentlich ein Exportschlager und das
Interessante daran ist dass diese immer
wieder Besinnung da drauf was in
Deutschland so richtig gut gelaufen ist
in all den Jahrzehnten dass die mir
nicht intensiv genug ist ne dass wir
also immer denken wir müssen mit
irgendwelchen Wellen mit Schwimmen ich
so habe ich die neoliberale Zeit erlebt
ne die immer noch nicht ganz zu Ende ist
was wir gedacht haben müssen das machen
wie die Amerikaner dann waren die die
Rede von AH wir haben so viele
Arbeitslosen Schröder Zeit wir müssen
das machen die Blinden mit Minijobs hier
und da und so weiter wir haben uns
eigentlich immer an irgendwas angepasst
wo wir dachten das ist jetzt gerade im
Trend und das müssen wir machen und ich
finde immer das uns im Vergleich zu den
anderen Ländern ist unseren
Selbstbewusstsein gefehlt hat
weißt du ich möchte kein
nationalistisches Deutschland aber ein
selbstbewusstes Deutschland das auch
stolz darauf ist dass es ziemlich viele
Dinge besser hinkriegt als viele andere
Länder in der Welt und zurecht stolz
drauf ist nicht am besten ja wir müssen
keine Superlative sein Skandinavier
können das auch gut Holländer sind auch
nicht so übel und so weiter ist schon
klar aber dass wir sozusagen dieses
dieses Vertrauen darauf was uns
eigentlich wirklich gut macht ich finde
dass das nicht nicht intensiv genug vor
Augen geführt wird und eine der Dinge
die uns eben über lange Zeit sehr gut
gemacht haben war dass wir sehr gute
Mechanismen des sozialen Ausgleichs
gefunden haben und damit komme ich
wieder zu meiner ursprungsthese
Liberalismus in Reinform ist total
scheiße
Kommunismus oder Sozialismus in Reinform
und ihm Zink gebaut ist ja aber die
richtige Kombination dafür immer wieder
auszutarieren das ist eine fortwährende
Aufgabe das heißt soziale
Marktwirtschaft und liberale Demokratie
sind keine statischen Systeme wir können
nicht sagen dass er meine Adenauer Zeit
erfunden und das bleibt so wie es unter
anderem war mein Gott was haben wir
nicht alles verändert wir haben zum
Beispiel auch wirklich ernsthaft mal
entdeckt dass Frauen auch
menschliche Wesen sind und dass sie die
gleichen Rechte und Grundrechte und
Möglichkeiten und Chancen und
Fördermöglichkeiten und so weiter wir
haben viel dazu gelernt müssen auch
weiter dazu lernen gerade den
Umweltfragen wenn ich sage
nachhaltigkeitsfrage ist die wichtigste
Frage der Menschheit dann habe ich dafür
eine liberale Begründung eine rein
liberale Begründung
der Kernsatz des Liberalismus lautet in
ursprünglich aufgestellt von Wilhelm von
Humboldt und von John Stuart Mill in
seine bekannte Formulierung gebracht
dass die Grenzen der Freiheit dort
aufhören wo die Freiheit anderer
beeinträchtigt wird also Maxime ist so
viel Freiheit wie möglich für den
Einzelnen aber eben nicht auf Kosten der
anderen
und wenn wir gerade die Ressorts in der
Welt vor frühstücken und den CO2
entstand immer weiter erhöhen so dass es
dazu führt dass künftige Generationen
kein angenehmes Leben mehr auf diesem
Planeten haben dann beeinträchtigen wir
die Freiheit unserer Kinder und
Enkelkinder und was der Liberalismus aus
historischen Gründen verständlich nie
auf dem Zettel hatte ist dass die
Freiheitsrechte künftiger Generationen
im gleichen Maße in den Freiheitsbegriff
aufgenommen werden müssen wie die
dagegen Generation dass die große
Lernaufgabe der Gegenwart und das hat
auch das Bundesverfassungsgericht ja
genau in diesem Sinne so entschieden und
deswegen wundert mich natürlich dass die
FDP müsste eigentlich der Vorreiter ja
der großen grünen ökologischen
Transformation sein genau unter dem
Aspekt die Freiheitsrechte künftiger
Generationen zu schützen aber da sehen
sie für sich keine Nische weil sie
glauben dass die Wähler wenn sie ihm das
Erzählen dann die Grünen wären genau
total interessant wenn man wenn man mit
ihnen darüber redet deswegen auch die
sehr unglaubliche
um die Frage geht sollten wir jetzt doch
mal über ein Tempolimit nachdenken zum
Beispiel da kommt dieses Nein immer mit
einer dermaßen Überzeugung das ist das
Alleinstellungsmerkmal der FDP ich
glaube die AFD ist vermutlich auch gegen
Tempolimit ja aber die spielt ja in
dieser Diskussion keine Rolle aber die
CDU auch also muss aufpassen ich muss
aufpassen dass das dass das Tempolimit
nicht zum Marken kann der FDP wird ja
aber dann hat man verloren ist richtig
Richard das war sehr inspirierend in
vielerlei Hinsicht hat Spaß gemacht
danke sehr ja ich danke dir bis dann
alles Gute Markus
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und Pots
bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]